سيتي ماكس كان هناك من دون توقف صعود
وهبوط في هذه العلاقه كما بين زوجين ولهذا
شبهت العلاقه بعلاقه بين شريكين هناك
الكثير من النقاط المشتركه بين البلدين
والكثير من المصالح المشتركه ايضا لقد
تسنى لي ان اقول ذلك للرئيس بوتفليقه هناك
كل المشكلات المتعلقه بمكافحه الارهاب
وتهريب المخدرات في فرنسا لدينا جليه من
اصول جزائريه مهمه جدا لدينا الكثير من
الشباب الذين يحملون الجنسيتين الفرنسيه
والجزائريه في كل مره ازور الجزائر احاول
ان التقي اياها هؤلاء الشباب كل هذه
الامور تدفعنا للعمل معا احيانا نقوم بذلك
ولكن احيانا اخرى لدينا تاريخ ومصالح ربما
تكون غير متقاربه قد تؤدي الى
اتذكروا زياره الاولى للرئيس الجزائري
كانت قبل العام 2010 بدانا بالكلام عن حرب
الجزائر قلت له انذاك وحتى نهايه الحرب
الجزائريه كان عمري 14 عاما وتاليا انا لا
اتذكرها وهذه من الماضي ماذا علينا ان
نفعل الان هل نبقى في الماضي ام نتحدث عن
مواجهه تحديات المستقبل وهذا اللقاء الذي
كان من المقرر ان يمتد الى ثلاثه ارباع
الساعه امتدا الى نحو خمس ساعات حيث جلسنا
الى مائده الغذاء ودعه وزراء واعتقد اننا
نجحنا في اقامه علاقه قائمه على الثقه مع
نظراء الذين تعاقبوا وهو ما سهل تحقيق
الكثير من الامور في مجال مكافحه المخدرات
اذكر انني نظمت لقاءات بعيده عن الاعلام
وهو عدنا على ان نقوم بامور مشتركه مع
بعضنا وهناك ايضا مشروع الاتحاد من اجل
المتوسط حاولت ان اقنع وان اشرح هذه
الفكره في بعض الموضوعات التي لدينا
وجوهات نظر مختلفه فيها مع جزائر ولكن
نحاول دائما ان نقوم بخطوات من اجل احراز
تقدم ومن اجل خدمه مواطنين قبل اي شيء
عن حقبه الاستعمار عن المجازر التي
ارتكبتها القوه الفرنسيه في الداخل
الجزائري لماذا من الصعب على فرنسا الدوله
وليس الاشخاص الذين لم يعيشوا ربما في
كثير منهم تلك الحرب لماذا من الصعب عليها
ان تتفهم حاجه الاخر ايضا وفرنسا هي فرنسا
الحريه
انت تفهم ان للاخر ايضا حاجات ورغبات
ودوافع للتحرر من ارث الماضي ثقيل جدا
عليهم
فرنسا تفهم ذلك جيدا ولا سيما ان تاريخ
فرنسا هو تاريخ اليم ولن اعود الى
الاستعمار الروماني واعتقد ان الرؤساء
المتعاقبين منذ جاك شيراك والرئيس الحالي
ايمانويل حاول كتابه تاريخ المشترك وهذه
افضل طريقه من اجل تقاسم هذا التاريخ نحن
نعيش في عالم خطير جدا يرتفع فيه منسوب
التوتر وتاليا ان مسؤوليه كل دوله هي ان
تحضر للمستقبل حتى يكون هذا المستقبل امنا
ومريحا لمواطنيها وهذا الامر يتحقق من
خلال العمل المشترك بين الدول والمواطنين
وانا تحدثت عن هذا الموضوع قبل قليل وكنت
في كل مره اطلب من السفير تنظيمه لقاء لي
مع شباب او الطلاب الجامعيين او الفنانين
في كل مره كنت اشعر بالدهشه لانهم كانوا
مهتمين بشكل اساسي بتنميه العلاقات وكيف
كنا نحن الفرنسيين نستطيع ان نساعدهم من
اجل استخدام مواهبهم في هذا المجال
لرمزيه الامر لخطورته على الكبرياء
الفرنسي او لانه يحمل فرنسا بعد قانونيه
وماليه ربما
هناك دائما مجموعه تطالب دائما فرنسا بدفع
تعويضات للجزائر ولكن هذا الامر يتطلب
اعاده درس كل شيء في شكل كامل وفي هذا
الاطار قدم الرئيس اقتراحا وعلينا ان
ننتظر نتائج ذلك بالنسبه الى الماضي هو
الماضي من الطبيعي ان نقوم بتحليل هذا
التاريخ بصوره مشتركه حتى نتفادى تكرار
الامور السلبيه التي حدثت في الماضي وهذا
ربما هو دور المؤرخين القادرين على
التفريق بين الصح والخطا وما ينبغي تفسيره
بهذه الصيغه او تلك اما دور المسؤولين في
الدوله فهو يتمثل في العمل ازاء الاوضاع
الدوليه الخطيره والوطنيه الصعبه حيث نرى
تصاعد اشكال العنف وسوء الفهم بدفع احيانا
من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وهو عنصر مهم
جدا على المستوى السياسي اعتقد ان دور
المسؤولين السياسيين وربما قبل كل شيء
يتمثلوا في الانتباه على الحاضر والمستقبل